folks joe derosa here guess who's back
on the road officially the run
has almost
begun
i don't have a name for this run yet of
shows quite frankly i don't like what
people name their that doesn't matter
listen here's where i'm headed july 9th
fairfield connecticut july 14th through
16th san francisco california july or
sorry august 12th through 13th atlantic
city new jersey september 1st through
3rd san diego california september 12th
somerville massachusetts and then dates
to follow in wilmington holland michigan
grand rapids michigan man i'm back out
there
go to joey
go to jotaro
fudge
go to rosa info.com go to
joederosainfo.com
and you can get your tickets there for
most of the gigs and the ones that
aren't there yet will be there very soon
that's
joederosainfo.com for tickets also while
you are in new york city
you see it here we're in the rv at joey
roses come to joey rose's
in nyc the sandwich shop and bar for all
your sandwich and alcohol needs 174
rivington street we're open tuesday
through sunday
joeyrosesnyc.com for details thank you
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking say hey buddies
welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds back here in the rv
outside of joey rose's at 174 rivington
street come on down folks open tuesday
through sunday
joeyrosesnyc.com for all the info there
but as soon as we're done with this pod
i'm getting a fat kid yeah oh yeah i
might get a sandwich myself i
i occasionally i dream about the fact
i do i only
it's a double decker hero peanut butter
and jelly would
which chips in it it's just fun it's
wrong
i have no idea why you were laughing
as soon as the spot is over i'm getting
a fat kid
ah somebody called like a thorn
speaking of kids kids are welcome down
here at joyrose no i might get a uh i
might get a sandwich too i dip it only
occasionally now because when we were
first opening
i was here so much that's always eating
yeah i was like you don't want to burn
out on your own product how about this
babe so
joe skateboarder wow
uh skateboarding maybe new york yeah
yeah just just remember skateboarding is
not a crime if you've seen the t-shirts
so i will say some joe and i were at the
beacon a couple of weeks ago and i
wanted to get joey roses for our after
after reception a lot of friends and
family at the local show we ordered five
platters of joey roses and uh there was
some platters left at the end of the
night and i took a f
i i gave away well i took a full platter
home right
and uh i ate
you know i'm not one to waste but i knew
that i was against the clock how long do
you would you say your sandwiches keep
for in a refrigerated condition i gotta
be honest i wasn't sure i knew they kept
pretty well but i wasn't sure until you
got super bowl platters
and you were a firm
i believe three days out when i saw you
three days is child's play and you were
like bro they're still going strong
child's play yeah i i ate sandwiches for
six to seven i i ate the whole platter
it's about eight sandwiches in the
platter i ate on the by the sixth or
seventh day i finished the platter holy
crap i had a joey rose held up at a joey
rosa sandwich a day really yes sir and
they held up they held up that's great
news yeah i'm flattered yeah so i've
tried everything on the menu at this
point multiple times that that touches
me i look and you you slice them into
these nice four quarters so what happens
is with the platter at home i would eat
four i would eat four to make up like a
hero or five whatever it was but i could
i could switch it up that's really cool
yeah that's really cool and i'm very
flattered by it
it makes me feel that i'm part of your
life when i'm not around i don't know if
you realize how part of my life you are
when you're not around
tell
not just in a friendship what do you
mean what do you mean not just in a
friendship way not just in a celebratory
way that i talk about you positively
obviously and lovingly with people
obviously right
and i have friends and family that ask
about you and whatever which is very
nice
but also just in the gen day today
i mean i go into my target i've told you
this they get the practical joke
impractical joker's board game there
i see you
you didn't tell me this no i've
definitely told you this where i said
where i said oh yeah yeah i said that
i'm shopping there to budget my money
and then i look up and you have your own
board game
but like you are part of like i s i'll
text you sometimes i'll go i can't get
away from this guy yeah like i just see
you around i thought you meant it in a
more like no i mean it that way too i'm
saying i'm saying that's what i'm saying
not just in that i talk about you in a
loving way right not just as i celebrate
you as a friend and not just that also
friends and family say
when they when they ask about you by the
way
they ask like
my mom will say like how's sal doing or
whatever but you know like friends and
family mr rosa that's very nice friends
and family what mr say hi to my dad too
oh yeah but sure of course hello mrs he
cares he cares
no but when they ask about you i mean
like like i'll have like cousins or
whatever say like you know
like at thanksgiving like do you and sal
actually fight like that stuff like that
you know they want to know they always
ask this question
yeah or like i really liked when you
guys i was watching at work the other
day when you guys argued about this like
do you really think that actually i've
had more family members tell me that i'm
an idiot for my opinions really then
they side with you way more than me just
like the fans yes
my point is no i don't i don't know i'm
happy to know that i listen yeah i think
in the house i think you've leveled out
i think in the beginning
people didn't know what to make of your
style
yeah
and i think
i think that at first they were like
taken aback by you yes and then i
believe what happened to our viewership
is what happens with everyone who knows
you which is you start to understand joe
for who joe is then you start to love
joe for who joe is and then joe comes
full circle around and now i really used
to tell me like things like ah they're
taking your side you know
i think now we're on a very level
playing field i think they that they
know you the people who know you know me
and i honestly think that it's anybody's
bowl game now when we argue i agree i
agree i think i uh i think i have
potentially stepped into a murdoc in the
a-team role
here where they say i don't care if he's
nuts or not i love the guy yeah
that's true and i think that they see
you as our hannibal you're leading us
through this through this whatever plan
hannibal is tea yeah no no hannibal's
george prepared
the the leader
who's face i'm thinking the two
different things
man is i forget i forget no that's mask
no space from from uh mask do you
remember the mask the movie about the
game oh the toys bro oh the toy yeah
yeah yeah wait who's face facing 18
facebook no face man is um a b.a barack
obama i'm blanking on his name
yeah george purpard is hannibal
murdoch is what's his name and then face
man was played by um
oh oh dirk benedict that's
yo uh if i if there's viewers out there
that don't know we're talking about
find yourself some a team
it's a crack squad of people
that took on personal missions or they
uh they were vigilantes yeah or a
gorilla weird they were not recognized
by the government but they sort of
helped them it was kind of like one of
those you guys don't exist because yeah
i think they were sort of like in
trouble
yeah and the government it was kind of
like the suicide squad where you guys
don't exist but if you just do these
things but if we ever find out about you
we're gonna anyway they drove around in
an otherwise unmarked black van but it
had one red stripe on the side and i
don't know what it was about that red
stripe but this van is iconic you put it
up would you put up some of the most
iconic auto film automobiles let's talk
iconic vans or television intelligence
just iconic vans okay the shag and wagon
scooby doo scooby doo
18 18. dumb and dumber shagging wagon
dub
um
god i feel like didn't wayne's world no
it was the pacer but didn't they have a
van in the second one
there's definitely there we had a van
sunshine
uh all right iconic vehicles that's
brought it up she's got kit kit you got
the delorean
you got the ecto one
yeah right
yeah i mean i'll go if you want to go
into outer space the x-wing the
millennium falcon
i mean they're not you know
but i'd say you put the millennium
falcon in anybody's face they go that's
the millennium falcon that's it you got
these you can see sal not liking it
i know i know oh no
no
it's old i wouldn't get on that uh
well the pacer from wayne's world
yeah i'll tell you what i saw i saw a
screen used
x-wing on an auction site yesterday
the model x-wing screen used how much
the current bid
was 500 000
jesus can you believe that i got to send
you the link though you'll you'll have a
heart attack there's there's tons of
back to the future stuff gizmo is on
that [ __ ]
a used gizmo gizmo babe a screen used
gizmo hold on baby
what's the cost of that let's look at it
right now that's got to be like a mill
dude
he was actually the poster boy for it
gizmo sally you think deroza would be a
jedi
uh derosa
uh i think he's a he's a jedi turned
sith
i agree i'd be a jedi that has become so
disenchanted and hurt by the world that
i turned to evil
he but there'd be a chance
he'd be a sith that opened a sandwich
shop
[Laughter]
he's on tatooine
[Laughter]
that's so funny i'll take the uh darth
maul
look at this
that's great i'm i'm saying that's great
to you i'm not i'm not just i'm not not
i'm loving what you're saying i'm just
looking down
the bar at uh the what's the bar in
tatooine
the cantina big jason jedi he's like you
gotta come back dude
that's the cantina that's actually the
lower east side cantina yeah that's what
it is you know what you should have you
know what you should do at closing time
every night play
that is a good idea
that's a good idea what do you think i
don't have good ideas i don't know
you know great ideas
joe comes out with [ __ ]
six eyes he's like what could what's
that if jay was a jedi
if jay was a jedi he would just sit in
one of those chairs on the jedi council
and he would argue with you
without a doubt his jedi is definitely
robe hood
and then jay would argue when you'd say
jay we have to go on a mission he would
argue with you that we should just stay
in the chairs and watch youtube videos
you know i would love to see jay in the
um
in the jedi uh luke uh outfit the like
the leather outfit
i'd love to see jay in all leather i
would do it
oh my god we should recast star wars
with comics that'd be great attella's
yoda is very good that's really good
dude
[Laughter]
that's great
that's really good that's funny man this
is tim chewie
tim would be a good joey
this is a wild sight man i'd also love
tim is boba fett that'd be fun
look at this again
does have that like
waitress dress from arthur how much
first movie i ever saw on vhs four grand
arthur first movie i have a story i love
arthur but they got her dress that's
wild four grand four to six grand
starting bid is two grand
that's her screen used waitre i'm gonna
i'm gonna guess so i'm gonna bid on some
stuff here
look at this replica used the delorean
replica
starting bid 75 000 current bid 100 000.
this is a screen used
delorean but like a tiny like a
miniature yeah yeah a replica not like a
light up nope sorry light up full-size
delorean time machine replica
used universal this is what it says but
full size hold on let's read it do you
see they re-released the delorean as an
electric car now i
this might be a car dude
this might be an actual car for only a
hundred grand you can get a degree of
back to the future full-size delorean
time machine replica used for official
universal studios promotional events all
right but still current absentee bids
one hundred thousand talking to g for
[ __ ] for an actual delorean it'll be
auctioned june 21st
that'll go up to 500. you think so
it's just a it's just a promotion dude
they're saying to you the work is done
for you here is your own back to the
future it's not like there's tons of
replicas either you know what i mean
yeah they're giving you
like that's it they're they're like
you're gonna pay for
but the problem is you can't drive that
like you can drive it let's see i'm
looking around i mean
wasn't q telling us he knew a guy that
had one he was saying
he can't drive it because he's like
pizza's getting knocked off of it and
everything yeah but he had he has one of
the like the ones
yeah did i ever show you the uh
i can't it's fully operational it's
fully operational registered and insured
did i ever tell you that i saw a
to the letter i saw this on on the stand
on the expressway on the standalone
expressway and it's fully lit up driving
on the expressway and i i it was when i
had it was it was a while ago but i had
a video phone and i have the video
somewhere i taped it i drove alongside
of it lit up at night driving on the
expressway um
that's why
did you ever see the sketch we did we
did a pilot for spike tv and uh it was a
it was a sketch comedy show it was a
single camera show with sketches mixed
in and we did a we had a budget we got a
delorean and we did a back to the future
sketch no
it's a a minute it's a minute and a half
sketch we we we we we all dressed up we
all want to go back to different places
in time and mers dressed as like a sheep
herder q was a knight uh joe was uh murr
was little bo peep joe is a pharaoh and
i was like a powdered wig guy and we
were like this is gonna be amazing we're
gonna go back in time we're getting the
delorean we're
flying down highland boulevard in the
street in staten island it's empty we're
shooting a whole crew we hit 88 miles an
hour we scream right and then as we're
screaming and we're like oh my god hey
hey miles an hour let's do this
we're screaming ah and like we're
screaming like 10 seconds then you just
hear whoop whoop let me look in the
mirror and the cop's pulling us over
that's funny we pull over right
there's like two words in the whole
sketch we pull over like i should be
card he's coming he's coming cop knocks
on the on the thing the thing goes up
and he just and he just looks at us and
i go
what year is this and it just cuts out
passed out driving the car while i was
driving it on camera right because it's
a two-seater and the four of us sat in
there it was a 95 degree summer day and
so one guy was on the console i think q
was laying across the back window we
were cramped in it's manual steering and
we weren't allowed to put the air
conditioner on because it was ruining
the sound and so we had to go up and
down the street for a few hours taping
this and at the one point we were
screaming in there and oh the windows
had to be up and no air on
right because the sound so after like
the third or fourth time that we were
going and screaming i literally screamed
and fainted on camera how you doing man
i fainted on camera and on camera i
passed out and came to and the vehicle
just went to the side and went on the
grass
yeah and a guy like you didn't get hurt
you're right
jesus god don't know all the cars on the
road you know it's like closing no i
forget that i'm saying on camera i go oh
i passed out and i i literally come back
yeah you're lucky you didn't get hurt
jesus christ yeah oh my god that's wild
caught uh joker stuff being sold like
this
what's that like oh yeah man yeah yeah
have you ever had to fire someone for
like sneaking like
so i have held i have held on to like
one piece of memorabilia clothing almost
almost like for like i'd say two-thirds
of every bit we've ever done
and i have it in a chest and i want to
uh do it uh
auction for charity with all of it not
that who knows who what but i have all
these pieces like outfits reward like
things we said
but um we do find all the time
bootleg merchandise
full stores dedicated to us bootleg
merchandise yeah it sucks
there's no way to avoid it
we try to get them shut down but but
nobody's ever like snuck off with some
of your hair not that i think so no no
you have luck in shutting them down
uh yeah yeah if we get somebody on them
they get shut down all right okay but no
but there's so many it's
it's insane nice
well i mean not nice that they're doing
it i mean nice to get them shut i bought
bootleg merch of myself
it is and i bought stickers of myself as
bootleg and then i wanted to get my girl
uh i just came across this
and i thought it was funny so i bought
it from the person but it was my face on
a mug but just like a hundred of my face
covering the whole mug and i was like
i think that like this will make her
laugh so i bought it and it came faded
and i had to write to the guy and be
like dude this game faded and he sent me
a new one but he didn't even know it was
me
that's hilarious i see your face
plastered all over like every college
dorm room now oh yeah oh yeah they they
print me out on on quints or quilts oh
we're in the middle of recording yeah
sorry sorry i'm sorry um
uh yeah and they they just hang me on
there when i do college shows i address
it all the time the college kids have
taken they've taken my image and
likeness and
it means something else to them yeah
like uh i'm like the michael jordan
crying whatever the hell it is they put
me on their shirts tattoos of it and
they put me they printed on
tapestries and they hang the tapestries
in their dorm and from the ceilings in
their dorm room what's up guys
holy [ __ ] and i don't get why and i
asked i asked him all the time why and
they say that we worship at the church
of sal you're a lord and savior or some
of them are just like
we just love you or whatever and i'm
like all right and i think it's for some
other reason they don't want to tell me
to my face it really makes me laugh i
love it yeah
it's weird that you're talking about
this as people are spotting you left and
right
i don't know if yeah we should have left
that door maybe it has an energy to it
we're in the middle of new york street
right now i mean it's cool it's cool
it's uh as long as you feel comfortable
i gotta go shut the basement doors over
there
that's your basement over there yeah but
somebody they shouldn't have been left
over you doing it thank you so much
wait your basement is in front of the
laundry place yeah it's
it's the guy's work working on the thing
down there he's coming in and out isn't
he
oh is he just locks a man in the
basement that's what i thought
uh
oh look at this tight when someone parks
over there you're not supposed to
yeah i guess he is working on the thing
all right yeah now word from our sponsor
better help babes you know better help
there are champions on here uh we talk
about this all the time and i am at the
top of my game right now but i am also
at the bottom of my game because i am
exhausted i'm burning out and it is
really important that i don't have a
nervous breakdown i take the time for me
i feel like going to therapy is like
going to the mental gym and i think you
should too uh life can be overwhelming
and i'm sure you guys feel the same
thing i have lack of motivation
irritability fatigue etc
better help online therapy want you to
remind you to prioritize yourself okay
talking with someone could help you
figure out your stresses in life um
we've used it since we've done it i
think it's awesome because i was someone
who was always
i guess not knowledgeable about actual
in-person therapy and a little bit
scared of the price and the process and
dealing with insurance this can connect
you with an online therapist in under 48
hours uh they're real licensed
therapists um
they offer video phone and even live
chat sessions uh so you don't have to
even see anyone on camera if you don't
want to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and like i said 48
hours you could be on there with a
therapist our listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com tastebuds
you know it it's better
h-e-l-p-com
buds try it out hey buddies let's talk
about upside all right from cringing at
the pump especially right now to getting
an eye pop in check at your favorite
restaurant inflation is hitting us all
where it hurts right in the front and
back and it does really hurt uh that's
why starting uh starting ucu's upside
isn't uh is gonna help yeah it's an
incredible app for anyone who buys gas
groceries or dines out and let's be
honest we all dine out none of us buy
gas in groceries but we all buy now
with every purchase i'm earning cash
back thanks to upside so i threw this
app on uh
just a couple of weeks ago when they
started to become a sponsor and
i'm saying especially i don't know where
you guys are new york guest prices are
mid-fives i was in la last week they
were touching six why not get cash back
on that it is a no-brainer it's not too
good to be true it actually works it
works instantly it's easy this is one of
those no-brainer products okay i'm
earning cashback thanks to outside you
should too to get started download the
free upside app in the app store or
google play use the promo code taste
buds and get five bucks or more cash
back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more that could be up to half
off
next claim an offer for whatever you're
buying on upside check in at the
business pay as usual with your credit
card or debit card and you get paid back
it's that easy in comparison to credit
card reward cards or loyalty programs
you can earn three times more
with cash back uh a cash back using
upside so you guys everyone has a
rewards program now if you like your
awards program think about this you
learn three times up to three times more
using this app you can cash out at any
time it goes right into your bank
account your paypal or you can get an
e-gift card for amazon and other brands
it's a really cool option right there
upside uses uh users earning more than a
million dollars every week that's how
many people are using this thing that's
probably why they have a 4.8 rating in
the app store go read it up for yourself
check it out download the free upside
app use promo code taste buds get five
bucks or more cash back on your first
purchase of 10 bucks or more that's five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase 10 or more using promo code
taste buds
what's up guys i am finally announcing
another couple of dozen dates uh so if
you've been waiting every time i post if
you're like that's not where i'm from
that's not where i'm from this is your
time to pay attention they are on
pre-sale right now with promo code god
bless one word at salvocanocomedy.com
i'm gonna be in hamilton uh i'm gonna be
in toronto for the first time up in
canada richmond virginia hershey
pennsylvania all in october november
we're doing knoxville we're doing
atlanta
atlanta you've been you've been calling
on me babe i'm coming we're doing
birmingham we're doing uh i'm doing
evansville and louisville those are
rescheduled from the covet days and i'm
so excited to get to you guys
moving over to december guys we're going
to be in jacksonville tampa orlando
sacramento san jose and santa rosa those
are my dates right now the new dates
announced through the rest of the year
and then otherwise vegas july 15th is
going to be a great one
we're also in boulder colorado um we are
in phoenix and then a great weekend over
there in portland seattle and vancouver
so canada i'm finally hitting you guys
up florida coming through uh you know
north cali i'm coming through all
everything's available this week and
it's all on salvation comedy.com check
it out i hope to see you there
all right anyway
let's get into the battle
you want to get into it right now i
think so right i mean you know it's been
a minute since we've done the worst of
uh our first worst of might have been
worst fruit
pear versus cantaloupe
yes and i lost that and then we did a
worse drink
you had to
no no pun but you got creamed there
and i took grapefruit juice
son of a [ __ ] so your track record for
a worst battles
is a business
yeah but this this is where it gets
confusing
it's isn't it funny that dismal and
abysmal kind of mean the same thing
no
but they're two completely different
words beside the mole
but beside that
i mean
dismal and then abysmal i don't know
that
is that weird aren't they aren't they
synonyms it's like they're two they're
not no they're not synonyms they're not
synonyms they're similar but they're not
synonyms
the um
uh
the uh the uh they're not synonyms but
they're uh
i don't know
i can't tell if that's weird or not this
if i was gonna be like
dude it's dismal in there dude it's
abysmal i don't know i feel like they're
the same thing all right fair enough um
so here's sometimes that might be a name
a good name of a band dismal abysmal
i don't like that at all okay i'm sorry
i'm not trying to be difficult
but this is where people get confused
with these episodes you'll see in the
comments they'll go oh i thought you
were saying which is better
they'll still think it's right no we're
telling you right now
i'm battling for the worst so if the if
you think it's the worst well
they get it when they watch it on the
polls i mean
well i put in all caps which is worse
okay so unless we have
you know people from
off a boat from somewhere oh boy you
know all right take it easy will you
let's not get cancer i'm saying no i'm
saying maybe if they don't know our
language or culture maybe they would get
confused right okay well cancel why
would you don't cancel i think it's the
off the boat part that's probably well
i'm just saying if someone came here
that's not from here that doesn't know
our language they would be confused sure
i got you i know i was just kidding i
don't think i know you're kidding but
i'm diving into it because i don't agree
all right we're doing worst
i mean not just which is worse we're
doing what we think are the worst
serious
and we're battling
uh on behalf of which shiro we think is
the worst
you are taking
i mean i'm taking
the worst cereal i've ever tasted and
from what i gather the worst cereal that
most people i know has ever tasted and
that is grape nuts my friend which i
don't even know if they still exist i
think they do oh they do because it's
for people over 90 and i i think it's
for animals but
they do have to have
that's the one food in the store where
you're like you have to have something
for people in their 90s or will look
ageist in the store right they have
grape nuts
it's wild right because
it's like how small the baby food aisle
is it is they have grape now yeah yeah
so the thing about grape nuts is there's
no grapes and there's no nuts oh boy
who are you what's the deal
what's the deal with oval teen why don't
they call it round team yeah um
is that what is that was that no the can
the jar is round
the cup is mound your mouth is round why
not call it round two the way
spanish is reading banyan's reading it
back to him
[Laughter]
because he wrote it he's getting all the
beats yeah like yes that's how i wrote
so so funny so the thing though but the
thing about it is two grapes i love
they're delicious nuts i love they're
delicious so it's so funny that not only
are they in it but they're com the name
is comprised of two delicious things
that are
not the same at all that i think most
people love i don't know why or how can
you google pimp with where they have the
stones speaking of stones they taste
like little stones and they truly do
they chew like little stones it's like
little gravel it's it's like if
rabbit [ __ ] became hard
or gravel got just soft enough that you
can crunch on it when i was a kid i used
to see the commercials for grape nuts
yeah because they had commercials that
really sold the grape nut which is what
a commercial is supposed to do
i wanted these things so bad i thought
it looked like such an interesting fun
cereal as a kid and in the commercial it
looks like couscous
i pictured a tasting like you know like
a granola flavor right like a sweet like
whatever and when was your world rock
take us through it
i never got them i think i would ask my
mom for them and she just wouldn't get
them for me because she was like you're
not gonna like them and i think i
finally when i was in college
and there were a few of us like i always
wanted to try these and we tried them
and we were like
we remember we eating we were like my
god like the milk is all gone where did
it go
and then we were going back and
refilling the milk and then we were like
a second time like the milk is gone
again yeah what is going on we're like
this is the worst cereal i've ever had
no it should that should be the slogan
for grape nuts grape nuts dear god where
is the milk i i i bought grape nuts once
in my life my family got it and i never
eaten it again and the first time i
chomped down i was not prepared for how
hard it would be i almost blew out a
molar
well i'll tell you this now i'm taking
as bad as i think grape nuts are and i
think they are terrible i taken the
battle
un
frosted shredded wheat
i will tell you also i think it's also
in the conversation so i think this is
going to be a tough battle i think it's
in the conversation because those are
like uh
little
little bricks made of hay and [ __ ]
unfrosted shredded wheat is when your
doctor goes it's
i mean i can't think of any reason for
eating it otherwise right like you still
want to eat something
harsh but you want to eat everything you
are about to eat everything you name
that you eat is going to kill you
there's one thing left for you to be
able to eat yes and it's wheat that has
been shredded and unfrosted and pressed
into a brick
form so so pimped give us before we hit
the actual battle give us why grape nuts
is called that so grape nuts 1897.
uh wait it was invented hold on it was
created in it post cereal was around 18
by the way shout out post you really
missed it with grape nuts but i gotta be
honest i got to give you your props for
alpha bits there is some interesting
stuff here so it's made from flour salt
and dried yeast
that sounds like a delicious cereal
flour salt and dried yeast
its lightweight and compact nature made
it perfect for
expedition groups in the 20s and 30s to
explore the country and have food so
this was basically feed bag food
it's the same as putting a feed bag on
you it's it's transferable portable
magic beans
it sounds like an army the army in that
time period figured out how to can
edible food for men in the depths of of
foxholes and grape nuts is still that
unedible yeah
wow grape nuts is for people traveling
very far by horse
actually grape nuts was in the rations
the jungle rations
jesus christ and yet it's still around i
gotta tell you too
i'm not with you at all on post i think
alphabet i think aside from the cuteness
of alpha bits they stink what about what
about a golden golden smack golden uh
golden not golden grams
golden though okay so there's sugar
smacks with the frog
beat it golden head the bear the honey
bear
yeah golden watcher mccall don't waste
my time that's not slept on cereal that
was a cereal very popular in the 80s
no one eats it anymore i think it's a i
think it's a it's a it's a passable
cereal what's that called golden crisp
honeycrisp no
it was a it was a bear and it was the
same thing sugar smacks no but sugar
smacks was the frog golden crisp golden
crisp
uh
i got to tell you post raisin bran beat
it i mean it can't hold a candle to
kettle at kellogg's it just can't i'd
agree
but in a in a bind i'm fine with post
raisin bran i actually don't like it
because i it's the the difference in
taste is so different
unfrosted shredded wheat that's a good
question that's what i was going to ask
uh so again this is an older cereal
whose horse is unfrosted shredded wheat
um hold on i just had his name
henry perky invented shredded wheat in
denver in 1890
oh it's the battle of the the 19th
century dude
is brutal all right but but what company
puts it out today pimp what company
produces it this well back in the day
was a serial machine company
but let me see who owns it right now
honestly you could fashion like a
like a nest or a hut out of un unfrosted
shredded wheat
you know what i mean you could use that
as a main you gotta you got some nice
clay and you use those as the bricks
i feel that you could build a hut out of
the wheat and then
lay a full driveway with the grape nuts
[Laughter]
uh cal it says post kellogg's
post wait wait post kellogg's the same
thing
see we these day in these days you don't
know there's big cereal there's
conglomerates now yeah i'm not sure wait
a minute is post kellogg's the same i
don't think so in 2000 crafts food water
uh see there's no more there's no more
uh
just pure straight-up brands anymore but
wait a minute so kellogg's now just has
all raisin bran
so they're putting out raisin bran on
the two under two banners
they might be just
i mean like you got to tip your cap i
mean
it's a shame it's all been corporatized
has raisin brand done anything
they added nuts
razor brand crunch added nuts they've
done anything else
uh they did that but i'll tell you what
well no
but i'll tell you what i don't think
i'll tell you what the best part about
that raising marine crunch was
the way they forget the crunch part the
crunch part was fine i i could take it
or leave it it just tasted like granola
or whatever
um
but the way they took the raisins and
rolled them in that like doughy
whatever i don't know what it was but
the raisins in that one had like a
coating on them of like almost like
dough it was so is that yogurt maybe
okay but it was like
i i don't know what it was man but man
they offer huh raisin bran with bananas
raisin bran crunch raisin bran vanilla
almond
and raisin bran cranberries
raisin bran what cranberries wait you're
telling me there's what there's
like dried bananas in there yeah or
banana taste i think dried bananas oh
man nothing nothing gets me going like
slicing the banana into a bowl of cold
cereal milk uh i think i would agree
with that you get some you get some uh
you put it in frosted flakes i go
oh i never did it in frost because
frosted is too much on its own i do it
in regular corn flakes i do it in rice
krispies i do it in cheerios
and cheerios absolutely you sprinkle but
you got to do the sprinkle the sugar
sprinkle i take a domino's packet and i
ration it yeah i do one coating of the
whole top i eat the top i do another
coating halfway through it's very smart
yeah that's very smart rational i don't
do it anymore but as a kid
oh my god you ever pour someone so many
domino's sugar packets on these shows as
a kid that when you're done with the
milk of course and you go to drink the
milk there is it literally a it almost
looks like like like coffee like there's
just a mound of sugar at the bottom it's
like cement yeah
yeah yeah those are the days those were
the days it's heavy stuff it's heavy
stuff the uh
shredded wheat when you're biting into
it too it really feels like you are a
cow in the pasture
folks let's talk about factor as the
weather gets warmer
factor can help you spend less time at
home in the kitchen and more time
enjoying the springtime the summer
summer summer time with no cooking
grocery shopping or dishes this is
pre-prepared
meals plus you get the perfect health
conscious grab on the go add-ons like
smoothies and juices luckily uh i don't
have to meal plan or prep and i can
still eat well now that i leave my meals
to factor factor makes it easy for me to
eat clean 24 7. with fresh never frozen
remember that prepare cause other other
ones are frozen prepared meals that are
so delicious you wouldn't even believe
they're actually good for you i like to
do a meal prep for the week especially
when i'm back filming and stuff like
that a lot of times on set craft
services is not healthy and so i will
literally bring a lunch especially when
i'm trying to eat more healthy and i
have to prep that for the whole week now
at factor i join i sign they get
delivered to my house and i have my
week's food just lined up right in and i
just grab it on the way out of there and
no more it's cut down in your outbursts
on set where you you flip tables over
yes like you've hit chefs yes like the
outburst you just had in the middle of
my read
[Laughter]
feel good for summer choose from factors
calorie smart and keto options with
built-in portion control as a great tool
to help you get fit for the summer and
that's the thing i learned too it's all
about porsche control babes factor now
offers 30 meals a week you can choose
from a variety of new meals every week
on top of that factor gives you the
option to change it up select any plant
size between 4 to 18 meals a week so if
you don't need that many you scale it
down busy schedule lunch dinner it
doesn't matter you can add an extra two
three or four meals to order if you
change your mind they save you time they
deliver fresh
chef crafted meals to your doorstep
eliminating grocery shopping meal prep
and cleanup each factory meal arrives
prepared and ready to eat in two
minutes that's even faster than ordering
uh we got this first as a sample i got
hooked on it and i still use it uh to
this day head to go geo go.factory
tastebuds120 not the easiest promo code
in the game not the easiest instructions
but let's go through it again and then
use the
code tastebuds 120 to get 120
off that's a lot so let's do this again
that's code taste buds one two zero
you're gonna go to go
dot factor
seven five the numbers
dot com
slash taste buds one two zero for a
hundred and twenty dollars off you just
just hit the 10 second back and listen
to that again and try it because i
promise you you'll be happy with factor
buddies i love talking about babel babel
sponsors our show they are a language
learning app they are the premier
language learning app uh i've been using
them for about a year now brushing up on
my espanol
uh some of you may know that i'm half
spanish uh uh akio quiero trago oro
that means uh give me a drink or i'm
gonna break the radio
okay so that's some of the fun stuff i'm
learning for all your summer travels
whether you're going abroad or staying
domestic and want to immerse yourself in
the culture now is the perfect time to
start babel i'm taking a trip to italy
second time in my life so i'm gonna be
switching off spanish to italian they do
have 14 different languages and i'm
going to start that now because i'm
going in about a month and a half and do
a lot of my commutes um you know on you
know falling asleep i take a 15-minute
lesson it's fun and i just kind of like
fit in language learning in my downtime
which is something that you couldn't
really do before something like babel
existed uh it's a language learning app
sold more than 10 million subscriptions
thanks to babel addictively fun and easy
bite-sized language lessons it's time to
learn a new language before you reach
the destination
for me it's naples with babble you only
need 10 minutes to complete a lesson so
you can start having a real life
conversation in a new language in as
little as three weeks if you're good
other language learning apps use ai for
the lesson plans but babble lessons are
created by over 150 human language
experts in the flesh the teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective i can vouch for it with babble
you can choose from the 14 languages
like i said there's also french there's
german a yada yada yada uh not swahili
but
you can write to them plus babel speech
recognition that technology helps you
improve your pronunciation and accent
which i clearly could even use in my own
language english accent there are so
many ways to learn babble
in addition to lessons you can access
their podcasts their games videos and
even live classes
the content library keeps growing comes
with a 20 money
back
20 20-day money-back guarantee can't get
hurt start your new language uh learning
journey today with battle right now save
up to 6-0 percent of your subscription
when you go to babble.com
tastebuds that's babel b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com taste buds for up to 60 off your
subscription babble language for life
first of all just back to the sugar
thing i did that
every time with sugar when i was a kid
but you didn't put sugar on sugar
already sugar cereals did you no i only
did it with chocolate juice yeah and
like rice krispies that's it yeah and
but i would just keep pouring it on
because i didn't
even as many times as i had all that
sugar at the bottom of the bowl i never
for some reason understood the sugar is
you're putting too much on it's falling
through the cereal right and i just kept
adding more like it needs more it needs
to the amount of sugar i ate as a child
up through my 30s
i
when i think about it now it's startling
to me yeah
it's startling it was like a five-pack a
day smoking yeah it was like so some
people some people didn't even use the
packets some people had sugar in a in a
in a bin a tin and they used to use the
spoon and that's how we did it oh no
actually i'm sorry we didn't do that we
had the we had the domino's box no no we
had the coffee house clear glass thing
and you could just pour it on oh my god
oh my god we had that thing poison
it's wild when i think that 70s and 80s
were wild
i mean just no regard for sugar no
respect for it yeah and it's power
and you ever look at you ever look at
cereal nutrition facts the serving size
is a cup
and when you pour into what we pour into
a bowl it's no joke it's probably four
cups it's crazy cup is of cereal is so
little cereal is uh is a ruse it's one
of the biggest roots the devil's gonna
play in cereal because we fall in love
with it you put a bowl of it in there
and you don't realize you have four to
five servings in a pop you pour pour
cereal into a measuring cup and see what
one cup of cereal is it's a it's a
fistful yeah i know i go i go heaping
bowl and then he and then midday mid big
bowl second round have you ever gone
giant bowl and you just go i'm not gonna
waste time refilling here i don't go
giant bowl and i'll tell you why
too much milk in there takes too much
time to get to the end you're getting
soggy it doesn't feel i i'd rather eat
more
i'd rather eat it across smaller bowls
the same amount than just one big bowl
right do you enjoy the big bowl i've
only done it occasionally it's fun
but yeah i agree with you it's it's
when you ration along it works a little
better yeah right great because i like
redoing it like all of a sudden it's
crunchy again sure i told you about the
crunch cup
no what's that crunch guppy if you're
watching and we know that you are uh i
guess this is free press for you i might
have talked
i stumbled across this thing on the
internet called the crunch cup when i
was christmas shopping this year and
what it is is it looks like a big um
almost like a water like a
like a water bottle like a sippy cup a
big sippy cup there's a cylinder in the
middle though that holds cereal and the
outside of the cup the cylinder is in
the cup okay and then the milk goes
poured on the outside so this
basically picture pouring up
a a cup of milk and then dropping in
cereal in a cylinder in the middle so
the cereal is in the middle of that cup
but not touching the milk
put a cap on it
then there's a system that allows you to
drink it like you're drinking from a
sippy cup but the milk and the cereal
are coming from two different spouts so
you drink the cereal into your mouth and
it's only you're only combining the milk
in the cereal as it comes into your
mouth so it can stay crunchy so you
could pour yourself a bowl of cereal and
instead of worrying about eating it in
that five minutes you could like eat a
bowl of cereal over the course of a half
hour and it'd still be crunchy you could
take it in the car and put it in it fits
in the in the cup holder that's
interesting i look cyril on the go it's
never been more easy crunch cup i find
that forty dollars i bought two of them
you better send a case to my house men
i
i find that fascinating i find that
fascinating
i don't think though that's what i
look on the go is a different story can
you talk about it but that's that one
because it was a deal i used one i
haven't used the other one yet would you
like it
do you eat well i don't eat cereal
anymore because everything that's then
don't take it you're right but
but i like
i would like to try it let's put it that
way i like you try joining i like the
the the evolution of the cereal and the
milk yeah that's feel i feel that i
would be being robbed of that
well you know if you want that then you
go to the bowl this is for when you
want to take your cereal in the car you
want to take yourself on a walk oh you
want you want you want to you know you
want to have cereal you're watching a
movie you want to have a cereal
throughout the movie and it'd still be
crunchy it's the people who love the
crunch also you don't need a spoon i
also but i also understand how is the
cereal pouring out of the cup into your
mouth right so the milk is on the
outside the cereal is on the inside and
then there's a cap and the cap has a
hole that touches both both receptacles
so when you tilt it cereal comes out of
the middle and milk comes out of the
side
there it is like the cap is big enough
that the cereal can fit through it
because all i keep picturing is cereal
getting stuck in the hole no no i mean
they thought of that
well i would hope so you see it looks
pretty cool right
i mean it's awesome but there's like so
many other things that need to be
invented still i can't believe this is
what's going on
all right i i would like to try it i
would like to try it
are you doing snap
i was like i said this is what i do i
say what's up to snap more times than
adults should per day i would like to
say hello to people snap
and that's not a euphemism folks i would
like to try it i would like to try it
i'm curious let's put it down i'll tell
you what you don't want to put in there
unfrosted you could put about three
bricks of unfrosted shredded wheat and
it won't work
yeah you need to bring we gotta get back
to the battle because we're we're just
we're way we're way down the cereal road
which is fine and we knew that today
would be a pleasant battle quite frankly
the last two weeks were quite heated
with nate bergatzi we didn't
worry too much that we knew today would
be pleasant because we were like look
we're basically arguing what's worse
we're not going to scream at each other
about that right but also it's okay to
have a nice day because last two
episodes man they were hot there was a
lot of screaming i could yell at you
when we did cream soda versus grapefruit
juice because i think cream soda is
delicious so not only was i arguing that
grapefruit juice was the the devil's
piss but i was also like you're crazy
for not liking cream soda but i agree
with you unfrosted shredded wheat we're
talking about what's the lesser of two
evils here i think there is i with that
said i think there is no way
grape nuts
there's at least with grape nuts you
have the shape for god's sakes like you
have either something there is nothing
redeemable about shredded rice i don't
know you have what's wrong what shape do
you have the shape looks it looks like
medusa looked at looked at couscous and
it became a cereal but you can still get
a spoonful and enjoy for a couple
seconds before the hard flavor hits
the texture of that stuff in your mouth
shredded wheat
there's no point when there's nothing it
shredded wheat you're right shredded
wheat does also remind me of of
insulation for a home oh
yeah i'd rather eat my insulation it is
weird like you bite into it and it's
like you're eating hay
yeah uh pimp did you get the medusa
reference
do you know that medusa
yeah yeah it turned to stone yes yes
by the way a lot of fans are writing in
uh both are perfect birthday gifts
really oh that's just a troll i guess
what a that is a very no that is funny
show up to someone's birthday party with
the two of them wrapped
well yeah and then especially if it's
like somebody's getting it's their 40th
you go hey
old
yeah yeah yeah that's funny that's great
i i would be hard now here's a question
i think grape nuts could be used as a
weapon in a way and i'll tell you how
not a weapon so much as a booby trap i
think if there's a home alone five i
think kevin could take grape nuts and
just throw them all over the living room
floor and i know hal and and marv or
whatever the hell the names are gonna
take a dive off of if i was gonna use it
as a weapon i'd use it like buckshot
that's true too spray it or throw it in
your eyes yeah yeah like mr fuji but i
also honestly believe if i took a piece
of shredded wheat wheat now i'm talking
before you break it up because it comes
in loaves
it comes in loaves in the box yeah i
honestly think if i took a piece and i
went like this to you
would it it would actually hurt oh you
you're you're true i would be injured
you'd break skin you could break skin i
think you could break skin absolutely it
almost is like a i feel like you could
like
sand stuff with it
yeah you know what i mean yeah like if
you just ran it over with some sheetrock
for a while you could like level out
some sheetrock yeah it's like a brillo
pad it's like little brillo pads i have
a friend who same chopper as before
wow it's not a bike baby it's a chopper
guys doing what motorcycle is this the
chopper baby i just i i have a friend
who would eat frost what is this that
baby you guys rode motorcycles who said
zed's dead baby
i've written on one i never drove one i
don't know i i
i always wanted to i uh q and i were
gonna supposed to take motorcycle
lessons together we signed up or
something like that and then i had to i
had to fall out for some other reason he
took the lesson got the thing got a
bike's been driving a bike for 20 years
i never did it i've been on a bike i've
been on a motorcycle but i've never
but not far either just use i'd love to
see you guys in the beach
i did it as a kid a couple times
a motorcycle seems liberating you know
what you could get i can get a three
wheeler or something with a side car oh
we should actually get
a branded wrapped license taste buds
motorcycle and side car
throw on goggles and a leather cap like
like snoopy like the baron i just drive
around oh my god
and honestly uh there's a way to like
attach mike's to us and just drive
around the city and do a do an episode
my dad was one of us
again my dad used to draw when i was a
kid that he wanted to get one of those
for him and my mom
and then my mom would ride in the side
cars
we always thought that was very funny
something very you don't you don't see
it here
i think sidecars are for war you need
somebody to shoot right
you know there was a gi joe there was a
gi joe vehicle with the motorcycle on a
side car
honestly if la's listening a sidecar
seems great for drive-bys
here's
good tip
here's my question
do you think there's a cereal on the
table
that can even step in the ring with
these two
disgusting hard cereals
because i'll say this too my buddy used
to eat frosted mini wheats
as if that was somehow healthy i love
the idea of that it was like i'm going
to offset the wheats now with by the way
wheat's not really great for you either
but like but you think they're trying to
set it up with a frosting it's like this
is like i just love that people think
something like that is actually healthy
but anyway do you think there's a cereal
that can that could actually step in the
ring against
google more seriously let me see
and grape nuts
yeah let's see what's one of those fiber
ones personally
the fiber ones that give some flavor
though maybe maybe one of those plain
original fiber one i love that cereal
maybe one of the original plain kashis
uh-huh you're right no nothing against
kashi but sometimes kashi's
i mean i think they're just sweeping
some stuff together off the floor oh god
kashi is brilliant and it's only healthy
because it also also has no other
nutritional value kashi tastes like they
they reverse the vacuum cleaner into a
bar
now i bought kashi before and they have
different stuff but i will tell you the
name kashi also has to go
kashi is not an appetizing name kashi
it's just not it's not it's not what i
think of when i think of i want to i
want
i want to eat kashi for breakfast
no it's disgusting yeah it's not uh
kashi can redeem itself with a little
chocolate here and there
you know some of them i guess they had
some fruit that'd be a good name you're
doing a straight up cosh forget it that
might be a good hip-hop name it might be
a good mc name straight
good for your body kashi is good
the uh maybe takashi 69 maybe that's his
thing takashi
kashi
wow they should get him as a
spokesperson
uh
that'll liven up that right now it's for
old people and ponies kashi i got to
close this thing pimp cut this part all
right
vamp don't cut it just close it it's
going to take two seconds it's the door
i'm trying to find i'm going to vamp
trying to find the worst cereal
but people oh he's going to close the i
thought he's closing this no he's
closing the the hole in the floor
there's one serial here called grin
smiles giggles and laughs i've never
never heard of that never hurt but you
google if you google worst cereals
there's not like an article with like a
little it becomes like an opinion like
cinnamon toast crunch
oh no no no no i'm not seeing like the
boring i said this before wow that girl
right now that girl had on no clothes
okay yeah
cinnamon toast crunch i had it for the
first time over the pandemic and i gotta
say oh tip of the cap
dude
i get it i get it
cinnamon toast crunch has those little
bakers that try to they're almost like
the uh rice crispy
elves what are they called yeah like the
little the rice krispies what are they
called
they're elves right yeah
tree occupiers i don't know are they
from the trees though i think they're
from the trees or the streets i'm not
sure
google that
their names are snap crackle you
remember frankenberry that's what's
coming yes oh they think frankenberry's
no good that's what this guy wrote boo
berry that's one okay it was count
chocula right
frankenberry and boo berry and i think
there might have been one more that is
one seal and that might be post as well
and that is one cereal uh
that whole brand i never tried
i never tried it
snap crackle and pop they're saying are
fairies they're fair okay joe ready
the mascots are rice krispies who are
they snap crackle and pop what are they
they're elves they're not
what are they so we just thought the
same thing well no now i'm seeing on
wikipedia saying they're elf characters
okay because you looked it up and
someone said they're fairies
okay take it easy people
guys it's 20 22.
okay they're elves
who do you think dog is pissing right in
front of you that's nice thank you
thanks now let's let them walk into this
honestly the lowry side is what most
reminds me of like
like a
maybe a
a a a an x-rated sesame street this is
the this is you can't get it
you can't get more who are the people in
your neighborhood than a block on the
lower east side i mean joe on the
x-rated sesame street's a 10.
let's do it pops his head out of the
sandwich window right there he's like
he's like the old lady
who pops her head out oscar no he comes
out of the can but who's that like like
what's her name on two two seven when
she pops
she's the lady that owns the building
yeah yeah yeah i love i love her or she
doesn't own it she's the uh she's the uh
she's like the building manager whatever
i see your honor i think i want to say
selma you ever see her on conan
no oh an old conan back in the day he
she she makes conan fall out of his
chair she they're talking about
something and then she ends up
oh uh conan makes an insinuation to
marijuana and legit straight up she goes
oh i love reefer
she called her reefer she was in a ton
of comedy movies
yeah you know like wasn't she in uh
but and like she would like smoke weed
in them like that was like a thing she
did towards the end of her career and
it's probably because she was like yeah
i'm into it like oh yeah cataracts yeah
yeah yeah the uh hoodie we've talked
about maybe discussing this on an
episode
i think we could maybe discuss it now
because we weren't sure if we could
carry a full episode but while we're on
the subject of cereal and we're talking
about snap crackle and pop
what do you think the best who do you
think the strongest serial mascot is so
what i was about to say before is people
don't give any any acknowledgement to
the sun that's throwing two scoops in
the raisin bran i think he gets some
acknowledgement he gets no
acknowledgement dude they forget about
that guy all right as a matter of fact i
wonder right now if he's still on the
box
he's the golden sun that drops in two
scoops of the golden raisins and i'll
tell you another thing here's one here's
something i don't realize right
grape nuts they had an ad campaign when
we were younger i showed it probably
shredded wheat i remember it but how are
these things still around they got their
hooks in the old people that they can be
occupying shelf space at your local
grocer still to this day with zero
advertisement when they taste and and
and crunch
how could they still be around it's what
i it's it's it's it's the it's the the
thing that battlefront is gonna be
phased out with the greatest thing like
what i was saying earlier about like
people thinking like shredded wheat is
good for you it's good for you if you
definitely you really need fiber right
it's great but nobody else has that
parent's generation is gone nobody grape
nuts shredded wheat they better really
they better go digital now because
they're
somewhere saying this is what you need
to go eat yeah there are those foods
that just won't go away yeah like i feel
like shredded wheat in particular
it's like corn
it's just there it's just gonna be there
doesn't matter how many people say don't
eat corn it's just like a bad carb and
sugar it's a veg it's always good to be
there do you think i think shredded reed
is kind of like that do you think it'd
be fun if we took like seriously like
took like
300 bucks
and we did a blind cereal taste test
right
would that be fun could we could you
identify like 50 different cereals
i was going to say what the hell do you
need three hundred dollars for 200 i
don't know 100 i don't know like seven
dollars a box or something
i could on the old school like kid
cereals i could nail every one we could
do one of like the worst tasting
right eyes closed worse tasting and then
we could do one of like just like can
you name the cereal but that might be
fun they do it on they do it on uh
hell's kitchen
right now with cereal i can't imagine i
wouldn't with a blindfold on
be able to taste spot
fruit loops
tricks
cocoa puffs
um um
uh
cookie crisp
count chocula
i wonder lucky charms like i'm lucky
they're they're they're all they're not
just discernible from flavor it's the
shape what was the mascot for cookie
christmas he a burglar
yeah he was a burglar yeah he was kind
of like hamburglar except he cookie
crisp still around
i haven't seen it
i haven't seen chris mascot i got it i
only had it once i got it during
lockdown and then i discovered chips
ahoy cereal and i switched over to that
and that was unbelievable it was better
than cookie crisps it was just they came
into the cookie crust basically
dominated them with their own game it
was unreal it was unreal christmas was a
wolf by the way it's like a hungry wolf
it wasn't back oh he wasn't a thief back
in the day was like a crook yeah he was
i remember he almost looked like um
yeah it was a thief back in the day now
it's like a hungry and he tried to steal
your cookie crisp is that what it was
yeah yeah what was with what was with
thieves in old advertisements like that
the uh ham burglar
and the cookie crisp guy and
the noid remember the noise the noise
the noid came and stole your stuff too
yeah dominoes yeah denoid that was a big
thing
good something somebody's gonna steal
lucky charms
no no i'm sorry trixx rabbit tried to
steal your tricks silly rabbits tricks
are for kids yeah i think trixx rabbit
might have the game locked down as far
as really oh let's talk about you know
greatest mascot him and um and and lucky
char what's the lucky charms guy's name
lucky bro i think it was lucky yeah
those two i'm kind of like
i don't know if anybody
i don't know if anybody was [ __ ] with
you first of all you you're crazy you
don't think tony's a tiger ah [ __ ] i
forgot about tony i think he is it
yeah yeah you're right then you guys i
think he's played out nah but he's great
you got two cans sam
follow my nose it always knows and sam
is good but he's not the truth
i think they also if they had a jingle
too cap and crunch bro
we should do a battle royale
we should do a battle of the mascots
tournament we should do a battle of
mascots all right all right you heard it
here folks let's stop talking about it
okay i love it i also think we should
take some money and launch a taste bud
cereal
i think you guys should design a cereal
that'd be pretty great
a limited run whatever 100 who the hell
can make it oh wait somebody else's
cereal wait a minute beside oh my god
you know what
oh my god i'm so sorry but saratoga
peanut butter reached out to us to re-up
on a new flavor if we wanted to
completely completely blank there was a
long time ago sure we could reach it and
then somebody else somebody else asked
us to make a flavor with them too do you
remember who it was saratoga let's do it
ice cream place i don't know shout out
saratoga you guys miss saratoga we
haven't talked about sarah talking about
saratoga peanut butter best peanut
butter on the market uh check him out
and uh i'll i'll get in touch with her
again we're gonna do a we had our own
limited run of peanut butter we'll get a
new peanut butter again but somebody
reached out to us and wanted to do an
a product when we could we do the taste
of it interesting i also got the uh
cartoon guys info for you guys too oh
great excellent yeah yeah and also is
there anybody out there that can help us
box a cereal that'd be
[Music]
but i mean that's the thing you got to
make cereal that's not an easy thing to
make i think that that's going to be
i don't think that's going to be
something that is going to return give
us a return i think that's going to be a
money pit
sure we could look into it we girls
should do it as a charity drink box i
just something small i would love to a
small batch here i could talk to laurie
my friend from shark tank see if she can
get us a package or a distributor shall
i want to make a limited run cyril why
she the blonde
uh well well uh she has i guess light
light dark blonde or light brown hair
okay you thinking of barbara cochrane
probably she's the short blonde yeah
she's a real estate that's just now lori
uh
she's the product person all right fair
enough
the uh i got what are we at pam 35
we're at 40 40. all right
the uh let's let's get into some closing
arguments with uh with shredded weed and
grape nuts but let's put a pin in a
couple things we're gonna do a battle
tournament battle of the mats serial
mascots number one number two saratoga
we're interested
hopefully we haven't missed the window
on that no i'll hit her up it was
another charity thing i got to do it
number three if somebody can help us
with a cereal
i don't know
i'd be interested in a conversation yeah
let's collab with somebody on a cereal
uh
last
our closing argument what would you have
kashi kashi call us
kashi we get what you're doing okay and
we get the most of your cereals but you
can have an outlier cereal that we can
help make your brand a little bit more
hip
on the streets all right and we will do
akashi
a healthy old it'll still be healthy no
what would what kind of cereal would you
go through would you go chocolate would
you have marshmallows in it what would
you do
i like it i like well i could go fruit
or chocolate but i
i do like the idea of a chocolatey
cereal like something along those lines
yeah i never ate chocolate cereal never
i didn't cookie cereal chocolate cereal
i just i honestly i might want to go
right in the middle with like a captain
crunch
with the berry flavor do you remember
donkey kong cereal
it was literally captain crunch uh yeah
i do and then i remember and they were
little barrels they look like
they had all the nintendo cereal that
pac-man cereal yeah the the mario one
was basically lucky charms if i remember
correctly
uh did remember nerd cereal or where was
it the box with the two flavors
i will tell you right now
my buddy my cousin is a big buffalo
bills fan and two christmases ago i
found a case of flutie flakes
doug flutie was oh yeah i remember those
yeah and i and i bought him an unopened
case of fluty flakes he was like 30
years old i think i want to go online
and see if i can find like pristine
unopened boxes of like donkey kong
pac-man like all those cereals we grew
up on
that would be fun to have eat them no
maybe i put them in like a display case
in my but well here's the thing they
make those again
they make like but like i'm saying like
they're go find those but then there's a
whole round of new stuff you can get
there's like a new super mario cereal
again like there's new fun seriously now
they look fun i see them and i'm like ah
it's funny that they kind of ran out of
serial options because every every
company has their version of something
like like donkey kong and captain crunch
or like sugar smacks and golden crystal
the same thing
same exact thing so it's like i think
there's only so much you could do with a
cereal but i also think like they're
missing out on the stoner market why not
license like golden girls cereal or like
better shows like aim for the stone that
would be interesting like a golden
grahams but it's golden girl cereal yeah
like a blanche head yeah well the kid
like younger people today don't know
golden girls no but it's four markets no
it's not a huge couple do you think so
oh absolutely sounds like now
yeah yeah the um i'll say this in
closing
before we go to see what this poll did
these two cereals
are hopeless
there is nothing fun there is nothing
good it's buckshot grape not says
buckshot yeah it this is
this is as i said in the beginning your
doctor is cornering you and saying you
got to do something here
uh and this is it like how do we not how
do we at least today at least today
how did we not get a box of grape nuts
in a box of unshredded
i didn't even think of it
because we don't think
we could be we could have been eaten out
of the box oh god
i don't want to it's horrible just a
bite it's been i only bit into grape
nuts once and that was that was decades
ago it was doing carter mondale well you
guys do own owe the audience a
punishment for last year so maybe loser
has to eat a whole box a box of this
cereal all right
that could be good through an episode
yeah two bowls
no no no
guess what time it is feed the meter uh
here's what you got to do you're going
to eat a full a full box
of shredded
unfrosted shredded wheat over the course
of one episode of tastebuds i couldn't
do it how so
i literally couldn't get it all down it
would be like dude do you know how much
carbs get yourself a 12 ounce box no no
how about this carbs while it would fill
you your stomach would be like a rock
it's a punishment a loaf of bread you're
like a pigeon eating rice at a wedding
it's too much i think while i'm setting
up one day we have joe come early and
power through the box before the show
starts i just got wild deja vu
crazy deja vu really from that to pimp
saying joe comes early really i swear to
god wild deja vu
all right pimp weird uh well
i'm not shout out deja vu
fun thing to say and and talk about i'm
not against doing this as a uh i'm not
against some version of this you have to
be punished the audience yeah i i know
i'd love to see you eating shredded you
know what can i dress you like i'll put
a little white powder in your hair put
you in a cardigan with like a nice
moccasin and then how do you eat a box
of shrimp unfrosted shredded wheat all
right
i don't know if i can eat a box that has
to be in the intro of the show for a
year
uh
i like the idea of the outfit i do
that'll do without question
pimp what do we got all right ready 12
000 votes okay
uh total yeah something's up with that
i tweeted that a long time ago we used
to get 50 000 votes saturday though
people are out yeah that's true saturday
so
in the park
the winner 52
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa do you hear
that 52 percent oh was a barn burner
oh wait hold on do you have it down to
the decimal over there or no 52.5
dude
to 47.5 two and a half percent this is
this is rematch territory yeah the worst
cereal is shredded wheat oh
ow
you needed a dub jesus dude i gotta be
honest i really didn't think that you
would top grape nuts because i thought
in popular culture grape nuts had more
of a stigma than unfrosted shredded i
feel like you just look you think of
shredded wheat
frosting i think it's the key no it is
through the name grape nuts at least
sounds like it's insane
shredded unfortunately there's at least
one
title
this the prefix on
unfrosted shredded wheat yeah they had
to put icing on it to get people to
choke this [ __ ] down
i still love you babe i love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds